this is suspect Christian B and a former
girlfriend who said to have reported him
to police for beating her up nexium if
tari has vanished from her German home
her family said she's in hiding in Kiel
jail Christian B has been moved into a
single cell for his own safety the prime
suspect in the Madeleine McCann case was
well-known in the town of Braunschweig
my heart was broken when I say the
picture film from Christian Bale from
this Cleo's brigita zegart II ran the
bar next to the suspects corner shop
kiosk this photo from Christian divide
assumed mine - king - Mangin tsongkhapa
is Vern shamea 38 and Phil de Familia
the famous cake layout theatre sea
moranga now Jason yeah Zowie better can
now sock industy Erin vision for the
skin tease klaus-peter Edmond is the
caretaker of a nearby apartment block
seeking that anger comes from you when
I'm here I'm back Christian well no I'm
gonna shake you become with a nice
finish - all concerning kidnap for
anymore do cuz the King mashenka your
arse offer imaginable kleiner the German
prosecutor says there's evidence
Madeleine is dead
but he won't say what it is Madeleine
vanished from her family's holiday
apartment in Portugal 13 years ago
convicted child sex abuse a Christian B
is the prime suspect for Madeleine but
police are reopening files on more
unsolved cases victims such as German
teenager Corolla Tita whose body washed
up on a Belgian Beach 24 years ago now
we have decided together with a
prosecutor to reopen the case and review
the things that we can find British
student nurse Louise Curtin vanished in
Germany 19 years ago facial reports of
this
Christian's activities cover a quite a
wide geographical range and a range of
Ages I'm torn between contacting the
police force directly and perhaps going
through the console every day the
suspicions around the suspect are
growing martin brunt Sky News in
Brownsville